would you pay to delete
a regretful tweet according to
information uncovered by an independent
researcher
whatever the hell that means for 299
a month twitter is considering a new
service called
twitter blue which includes an undo
button allowing subscribers to unsend a
tweet
for a few seconds after posting it or
who accidentally retweeted anything from
chrissy teigen
why where'd she go a useful tool if you
accidentally used your real account for
a tweet that should have come from your
anonymous steve ducey fan account
hypothetically twitter blue would also
allow users to organize favorite tweets
into folders
which definitely sounds like a thing you
should do instead of getting some fresh
air
dr drew has ever been a tweet that you
wish you could unsend oh i'm sure there
are many
yeah there are many but it just reminds
me about how much we're trying to
control language these days i mean
control the language seems to be the
overriding impulse everyone has i've
been i've been thinking a lot about
something abraham lincoln said recently
recently i've been thinking about it
recently which was that if the if you
call an elephant's trunk
a leg how many legs does an elephant
have four because calling in a trunk
doesn't make it a
calling a leg doesn't make the trunk a
leg and we are so busy trying to control
language these days
that we are just preoccupied with words
and twitter and messaging
and it's a big mess we should be getting
off twitter not paying them more
do that with a spider instead of an
elephant
it wouldn't make it up this would be a
good time to do it
yeah so for 2.99 undoing my tweet that i
was going to be on the show
it's looking like a really good idea
[Laughter]
you're not even on twitter are you oh
yeah oh you are matt whitaker 46.
oh there you go that means 45 people got
there before you
exactly all right cat this
seems like something that would be up
your alley yeah because some you know
sometimes you have like
you tweet something and it's so good at
least mine are
and then you notice you made a little
typo and then people might think that
you were tweeting while you're drinking
even though that's something you would
never do
[Laughter]
it's funny the ones that i regret i just
don't remember
did you see the did you see the press
about uh something that you wrote
and it's like some of the stuff was like
completely completely in my head
innocuous but
apparently people like to take things
out of context tyrus do you ever wish
life had an undo button tyrus every
morning when i get up
as i walk on the plane heading to new
york
it would be so nice just to go
but i live in the really real world this
is stupid don't give them a dime
you can't take it back somebody will
have it and even worse
on top of your bad tweet they'll be in
other news he attempted to delete his
tweet
so you really know how evil and bad he
is right
this is a setup this is a horrible setup
for someone who says something
and tries to delete it or they make the
mistake that's a good point i was 12
years old and i said something dumb on
twitter
i tried to fix it but while i'm trying
to fix it it's retweeted everywhere
and then then you can't get drafted at
21 because you messed up when you were
12. and twitter sucks now since
trump got kicked off yeah so i mean it's
like it's it's a dying
force yeah it's like the the funnest
person at the bar left the bar and now
you're just stuck with his weird friends
i don't know does tiffany tweet i gotta
look into that
they shouldn't charge you to undo a
tweet i mean that's just
again holding you gotta pay it's like
that you know it's like that big foamy
stain remover they used to have this
supermarket
before your time cap but it was a big
what did they call it the thing that
with the
foam and steam the steam
remover i don't know what it's called
but it's true the moment you remove a
tweet
somebody's gonna have a screen grab of
it immediately and you're guilty
why'd you try to remove it then yeah
exactly why i think you know the most
what would make twitter the best thing
is to remove
trends because how would the lazy media
know what a story is so they always are
able to
i would say like 80 of the stories that
we're seeing right now
are a producer or somebody on the show
looking at twitter trends
seeing what's trending and go oh this
person must have said something
let's go after that person but if you
remove the twitter trends
they'd all have to go back to drudge
that was a joke
but we can't go back to dredge because
drudges like
sucks it's true
but your point is well taken which is
that you say things are relatively
innocuous and they get twisted and as
they are trending they get twisted into
something else and the media reports
that as fact
exactly you can see fake news created in
real time on twitter no it's amazing
it's amazing and it's out of your hands
it's like a little
it's a little moral tornado hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else